(cris)uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiue
célébration d'Halloween est
rapidement devenu un cauchemar.
Des milliers de jeunes réunis
pour fesprisonniers des petitess
étroites du quartier
Itaewon, à Séoul.
Des scènes de chaos. Dans laenet
de fuir par tous les moyens.
s s s que la fête se poursuit
dans le quartier, au sol,
des centaines de corps inaniméss
par des couvertures.
Des équipe p p p p p p p p p p r
les blessés. Des hôtels,
réquisitionnés, sont transformés
en hôpitaux de fortune.
Un pos
est érigé.
"Les pompiers ont demandé de ar
à la réanimation", racontecececi
pris dans la foule.
"Je n'aurais jamais pensé que
ce genre de situation puisse
arriver enààààààààààààààààààààà.
C'était le premier rassemblement
d'importance depuis le début
de la pandémie de COVID-19
ni l'ampleur du drame ni la
cause. Des médias locaux
rapportent que la présence
d'une célébrité dans une boîte
cette bousculade meurtrière.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréa